نبدا حلقتنا اليوم بحديث الساعه نتحدث
طبعا عن حفل توزيع جوائز اوسكار في نسختها
الخامسه والتسعين فمزيد من السينما ومزيد
من التنوع حيث تمكن الصناع فيلم افيت
سبع جوائز اوسكار على راسها جائزه افضل
فيلم بالفعل خطفت الممثله ميشيلوا جاهزه
اوسكار افضل ممثله في الفيلم هي اول
اسيويه تحصل هذه الاوسكار في فئه افضل
ممثله
وحصد كل من دانيال وشائزه اوسكار كافضل
اخراج الفيلم ذاته الى الجواز الاخرى حيث
فاز الفيلم الالماني
او كل شيء هادئ على الجبهه الغربيه بجائزه
اوسكار كافضل في الدوله وهو امر نادر
نسبيا بالنسبه لفلناطق بلغه اجنبيه
وفي مفاجاه غير متوقعه فاز ممثل كندي
برندن فريزر بجائزه افضل ممثل عن دوري في
فيلم الحوت وكان فريزر قد عانى من زياده
كبيره في وزنه وابتعد عن البطوله وعن
الاضواء ودموعه على خشبه المسرح ما هي الا
حكايه للعوده للحياه على كل حال كل سنه
نغطي اوسكار مع زميلنا رافي بوغصيان اليوم
رافي شخصيا معنا هنا في استوديو صباح
العربيه في تغطيه خاصه من صباح العربيه
اليك رافي
شكرا نادين شكرا سهام اهلا بكم يصوت اعضاء
اكاديميه الاوسكار في سبع عشره فئه مختلفه
لكن الفيلم يجب ان يستوفي العديد من
المعايير ليتم اعتباره جديدا بالترشح
لجائزه الاوسكار اولا يجب ان يكون الفيلم
اطول من اربعين دقيقه وان يتم اصداره خلال
العام الذي يسبق الحفل ويعرض في دار عرض
تجاريه في لوس انجلوس لمده اسبوع على
الاقل اذا استوفى الفيلم هذه المعايير
يمكن وقتها تقديمه وفي حال قبوله يرسل الى
الاعضاء الذين يحق لهم التصويت في
الاكاديميه كتب الاصوات بعد ذلك الى شركه
الاستشارات في دبليو سي التي تحصل الارقام
وتصدر قائمه باعلى 5 مرشحين لكل فئه من
حيث الاسواق ثم يصوت الاعضاء مره اخيره
قبل ان توضع النتائج في الظروف مغلقه حتى
ليله الحفل اعتبارا من 2020
الاكاديميه حق التصويت لبضعه الاف اخرين
لتشمل مختلف الاعمار والاعراق وتتيح
الفرصه لمزيد من النساء كانت تلك محاوله
لردع الانتقادات القائله ان معظم الاعضاء
مسنون وبيض المشاهير والنجوم تفرش لهم
فوائد تتناسب مع فخامه الحفل عقب التوزيع
الجوائز فماذا اعد لهم الشيف ووفكا هذا
العام نتابع في التقرير التالي من اعدادي
انا رافي بوصيان
انت في افخم امسيه في العالم وفي حضره
اكبر نجوم الكوكب انت في حفل الاوسكار
فكيف تتخيل مائده الطعام في تلك المناسبه
خلف بريق الفساتين ومضات كاميرات التصوير
هناك رجل اعد اشهر مائده في العالم اسمه
وقد التقيناه في صباح العربي
[موسيقى]
الشيف يعرف ضيوفه جيدا ويصنع لهم حوالي 40
طبقا متنوعا كل عام لابد لبعضها ان تكون
مفاجاه لهم
[موسيقى]
يبقى الاوسكار الحدث الاكبر بنسبه لباك
ليس على الشاشه بل في الطبق وين الاوسكارن
غير معلن كل سنه لصباح العربيه
ومن احسن من يتحدث عن الاوسكار ينورنا
صباح العربيه من هوليود رفعت صباحك ورد في
الاستوديو اليوم الاوسكار معانا ميزنا
وجيت للاوسكار معنا اليوم
نتحدث عن جائزه افضل افضل فيلم الاوسكار
حدثنا عن ما يميز هذا الفيلم الفائز
بالبدايه اريد نادين تعترف انه توقعاتي
كانت محل البارحه خليني بس انا احكي
للمشاهدين انه اصبت بخمسه وغلطت بواحده
برافو عليك طبعا المفاجاه كانت انه شفنا
انه التركيز انه الافلام
حصلت على سبع جوائز من اصل 11 ترشيحات
وهذا يقول لكل الناس انه فعلا تتركز بشكل
كبير على التنوع
العرقي وشفنا انه
هو بطل فيلم the wail حقق جائزه افضل ممثل
يعني بالنسبه الي قدم دور كبير كبير جدا
حبيت البدايه
من افتتح اتوقع 19 دقيقه كانت في بدايه
الحفل من قدم وقال انه على الكلمه
الافتتاحيه من تطرق على صفعه
وقال انه انتم بامان لا تشيلون هام بس اذا
واحد صارت حادثه مشابهه رح نعطيكم
الاوسكار لانه اذا نتذكر العمل الماضي
ويرسمت هو سوى الصفعه بس هم طوله الاوسكار
عن فكان اعتقد شيء رائع البيرفور
اعتقد بصوره عامه الاوسكار كان رايح في
هذا العام طب يعني انت حضرت كذا مره يعني
بدنا بس كمان وكنت قريب اكثر لهناك
للحفلات كمان نعرف شو بصير وراء الكواليس
مثلا هون احاديث جانبيه ماذا يفعل
المشاهير هناك
يروحون على المسرح
عفوا يروحون على المسرح الدولبيث على
الفكره هاي اول مره يسووها من 1960 وهذا
الشيء تغيير كبير فيروحون على المسرح
الدولبيثياتور جدا رسمي بيسي يسمعون بها
حركه اكو عشاء ماكو جدا رسمي بعد ما يخلص
الحفل يروحون على
الكفرنيرز بول اذا مثل ما شفنا بهذا
التقرير مع الشيف بعدين يروحون على حفلتين
اللي هيوصل تقريبا 200 الف دولار حتى
الشخص يدخل والحفله الثانيه هي الارتنجون
وطبعا الحفلات مستمره في لوس انجلوس الى
الصباح طيب نشوف خلفك في الخلفيه الممثله
الاسي لاول مره تفوز في جائزه الاوسكار
حدثنا اكثر اول جنسيه اسيويه تفوز تاكيد
هذا حدث تاريخي اول ممثله من اصول اسيويه
بهذه الجائزه وانا اعتقد انه ميشالو هي
رائعه جدا وانا حبيت اصلا من اكيد حبيناها
في فيلم
تستحق واني كلش فرحان اني اشوف انه هوليود
جاي تتغير لانه هذا من يشوف احنا اكو
ممثلين الاصول اسيويه يفوزون هذا تناول
عرقي يعني يوم من الايام راح نشوف اكثر
حظوظ للممثلين العرب انه يحصدون على
الاوسكار
طبعا
تكلم
نا عليه
افضل جائزه مؤثرات بصريه وانحجنب هذا
الموضوع متشنق نتغدى
بينوكيو فيلم رائع وكان متوقع انه راح
يفوز بس خلينا نشوف بينوكيو لانه هذا
افاتار
هذا الفيلم المفضل طبعا
وسهام حبت فيلم
مع العلم انه
كان متوقع انه تفوز هو هذا الغلط
في مفاجات يعني في مرات بقولوا لك كثير
بصير في انتقادات بالصحافه الامريكيه انه
هذا الممثل ما كان متوقع انه يفوز
بالجائزه او هذا الفيلم مثلا والعكس صحيح
صراحه
الافلام كلها اوكي احنا امتى نقول مفاجات
يبلش موسم الجوائز بالشهر الاول مع الجولد
اوكي بعدين عندنا
الساق اورد بعدين عندنا كل هالمهرجانات
اللي تسبق الاوسكار
بهاي السنه
التوقعات كانت جدا جدا صعبه لانه الافلام
كانت جدا متقاربه يعني
جدا متقاربين فمثل جولدز فازوا بعض
الافلام بعدين
كانوا جدا مختلفين فما كان اكو توقعات انه
هذا الفيلم مئه بالمئه راح يفوز ولكن مثلا
عندك بينوكيو كان مئه بالمئه راح يفوز كيت
بلانشيت انه كان المفروض تفوز انطوها عندك
الفئه افضل ممثل مساعده اللي
هوى الممثل الاسيوي اللي سوى
يعني اليوم استلم الجائزه قال امي انا انا
حصلت على الاوسكار لانه هو كبر بطريقه غير
مستقره وبلش
بمكان اللاجئين فبالنسبه للاوسكار كان حلم
الحلم الامريكي فكان سعيد جدا بالنسبه الي
كان اسمها